la pandemia de Kobe 19 no ha terminado
pero su fin podría estar cerca
un corredor de maratón no se detiene
cuando la línea de meta está a la vista
nunca hemos estado en un mejor momento
para poner fin a la pandemia
el director general de la Organización
Mundial de la Salud
sin embargo insistió en que en esta
etapa no se debe bajar la guardia
el anuncio se da luego de que la semana
pasada el mundo registrara la cifra más
baja de muertes por Kobe desde marzo de
durante estos más de dos años según
datos de la universidad Johns Hopkins el
virus ha cobrado la vida de 6.5 millones
de personas más de 609 millones han
contraído el virus y se han administrado
más de 12.000 millones de dosis de
diferentes vacunas contra el Kobe 19
pero el surgimiento de variantes del
virus representa otro desafío en la
lucha por terminar esta amenaza
si no aprovechamos esta oportunidad
ahora corremos el riesgo de tener más
variantes más muertes y más
interrupciones y más incertidumbre
la esperanza de un posible fin de la
pandemia llega en un momento crítico
para la humanidad causado por la guerra
en Ucrania el riesgo de hambrunas y la
amenaza de una recesión económica
mundial